Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so the flash versus
Iris West.
Everyone's like what.
That doesn't make any sense, but he has fought
her twice in the last couple of years both
on the TV show and in the comics so this can
be an explanation so much fun.
There is a new round of the flash ring giveaway
going on now it's the holiday season new giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything during the break, so a
lot of your like wait a minute.
We're why would the flash ever fight Iris
West they're not together in the comics right
now but on the TV show think they've just
been like slowly pushing them together for
the last couple of seasons it in season one
big twist Hannibal Bates emulated her appearance
and they had a knockdown drag out Klingon
style fight so this is really the only way
I think this would ever happen on the TV show
with the flash himself would throw a punch
at Iris West.
So of course it was one of my favorite Iris
West moments from season one because you would
never think that the love interest of the
person they would cast to be the love interest
on a TV show like this.
Especially Candice Patton would actually get
in a fist fight with the person that she's
arguably going to be getting married to someday
we don't know if he'll ever actually get married
on the TV show they might do it Smallville
style were they get married like the very
final season and the very final episode or
they flash forward to like the distant future
we are supposed to see the future version
of the flash who gets into this big war with
savitar and varies been talking about a new
suit this virus.
And so the really couple rare circumstances
when the flash actually fights Iris West one
of them has to be my controlled or has to
be a shape shifter pretending to be one of
the other people.
So recently in the comics.
They had a speed of darkness arc flash versus
Iris West teaser or your like oh my god of
actually going to make them fight.
So if you haven't been reading the new flash
rebirth comics.
They basically reset a lot of the universe
and brought back the Ginger Wally West but
we also have the child kid flash Wallace West
twos the African-American the introduce during
the new 52 there are two Wally West but the
age down Wally West and he's been living with
Iris West, who is his on like is caretaker
so to speak.
She's not dating Barry Allen even had a different
love interest in the first big rebirth arc.
But that person went away.
So over the course of these first couple new
rebirth comic.
Arthur like clearing a path for Barry and
Iris to start going out and dating again.
But in the speed of darkness arc Wally gets
trapped inside the land of the nightshades
where the Shae draws his shadows from an Barry
has to go rescue him, but Iris very headstrong
just charges in and she gets trapped by the
shades to while she's in there, the shades
take her and turn her like poison her against
the flash so with in rapid succession.
You have two times that the flash has fought
Iris West it's almost like Superman fighting,
Lois Lane like there have to be some huge
twist.
You do have to take his powers away you have
to give her power somehow.
The twist here is that I irises been possessed
by the shades she gains their power the powers
of darkness, so it's this opportunity for
Wally West to manifest a new flash power that
we haven't seen before.
So it's one of those perfect comic book set
ups that makes you feel compelled to buy the
next issue that's the mark of a good comic
when you just feel like you actually have
to buy the next issues that you find out what
happens.
So if you don't know who the shade is they
actually just used him on the flash season
three in a slightly different way just like
shadows
in the comics he's a bit more of like an English
gentleman turn to crime, but in this story
line you see him after he's tried to become
good he met a woman fell in love try to leave
his life of crime behind but Godfather style
his shadows rebelled against him, and turned
him back to a life of crime and so he's forced
to work with the flash, to try and save his
girlfriend, and help save Iris West twos also
been taken by the shadows, but I like the
way he explains the Shadowlands the place
where darkness went after God created light
so that makes you think a little bit about
Green lanterns because anytime you talk about
light in the universe talking about the emotional
spectrum you talking about Green lanterns.
But this is mostly just the flash story so
one of the really cool things is that this
is like a pretty fantastic story that involves
a lot of crazy sets different costumes, so
you like with the ever do this on the flash
take into the Shadowlands were taken to the
mirror world or even to gorilla city, so there
is going to be a gorilla Grodd episode in
the back half of the season.
It'll be an earth.
19 story it will involve the accelerated man
Harrison wells tease that they have a gorilla
city on earth.
19 the will just follow up with that like
will be seeing more from this HR earth.
19 Harrison wells world, but you probably
noticed that with each new season.
The flash is use more and more special effects
to do like the crazier big stories most of
the time they use it to show off new cool
flash powers are battles with full CG characters
like Grodd or savitar savitar is like a Grodd
style character in that he is full CG.
So just like in this story.
They might show off the Sunburst ability like
Superman has that Wally West demonstrates.
So he basically like vibrate so much that
he gives off a burst of light, and it destroys
the shadows.
That's how he's finally able to defeat them.
They might do that on the TV show like the
lightning throw was the big season two think
they showed off it was this big special effect.
It looked really cool, but each new season.
They try to show off new powers the big thing
that Barry Allen is working on is learning
to enter the speed force at will, which is
like a giant level above where he's at right
now.
That's basically what savitar is doing when
he's appearing or he's jumping straight out
of the speed force, but because the way he's
trapped in the speed force existing in the
sort of in between state he can't make it
stick.
So let me know in the comments which comic
book abilities.
Do you think that they're going to give Barry
Allen the season.
Do you think it'll like this flash versus
Iris West arc the gonna give him the Sunburst
into do you think that will also see him learn
to enter the speed force without having to
be vaporized like he was in season two that
was such a cool scene where releasing chemicals
into a system
tonight Barry was struck by lightning.
He was doing fingerprint analysis.
The system then there going in have to re-create
everything that happened a very that night
now what can happen is is during the break.
I'll be doing more of these epic battles not
just flash characters but other comic book
characters if you want to recommend a versus
video like Superman versus Lois Lane stuff
like that.
Just write them below in the comments I think
the next one will probably be the flash versus
Supergirl, just because they've had a couple
episodes with them together actually tease
that they go up against each other you is
wonder who's the fastest razor technically
it's the flash but Supergirl is much stronger,
so that I should be pretty awesome fight as
he was faster.
So I'll say congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner David, you win the flash ring
I already started a new round of just announce
the winner the next time I post a DC video.
So get hype, happy holidays, everybody.
Hopefully, you started your break I've got
some Marvel be posting later tonight then
more Star Wars game of thrones walking dead
early next week while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for all my Star
Wars Rogue one Easter eggs and you can click
here to learn about the fastest speedsters
on the flash you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys tonight!